Or coconut products, okay, for a low histamine diet, you know, that's, again, that's something
that you, like if you Google foods with high histamine in it, you could, you could pull up
like six different articles, and there's six different lists, although there'll be some
common things in each list, but sometimes you'll go, this list has this and it doesn't have,
this list doesn't have that in it.
Because if you do organic assay of products to test for histamines, you know, I've said this
before, it's, sometimes it's very different because it depends on how old the product
is, et cetera, and how many histamines are in it.
So the percentage of histamines in a product is based upon the age of the product is just
based upon the, you know, the sample that you got of that product.
Coconut is that high in histamines?
I don't think it's generally high in histamines.
So, but you know, if you eat too much of anything, you can have problems.
So, but, you know, is coconut oil a substitute for some other things, or could I have coconut
in a meal that I make?
Yeah, I think that would be typically fine on a high histamine diet within a reason.